joining me now to discuss all this
author and commentator Bonnie Greer you
could see you nodding along to some of
that we'll come to you and conservative
radio host Ben Ferguson don't know if
you were nodding along Ben but we will
uh we will shortly find out Ben let's
start with you then I mean in all of
this a crime is a crime right of course
a crime has got to be tried in court
well look the problem is there's not a
crime that's committed here and it's
going to end up being thrown out this is
the dumbest case I've ever seen brought
especially against a former president
there's a reason why Federal prosecutors
did not prosecute the same crime when it
was before them the the former district
attorney in New York also in an
interview this morning said he did not
bring this crime against Donald Trump
when he had four years to do it because
he said he believed it was a ridiculous
charge and that was a liberal Democrat
who said that as well this activist D.A
Alvin Bragg has overstepped here
Democrats were begging him in the final
hours to not do this some of the biggest
allies of Barack Obama were saying
publicly on TV he's overstepping he
needs to walk back from the brink so you
just gave the biggest in-kind donation I
think in political history with this
indictment to Donald Trump you're
rallying troops behind him a lot of
people that didn't like Donald Trump by
the way are are giving him money which
you just mentioned in historic numbers
so I think this might be the biggest
backfire in political history as well
well let's see if we can tip out the
scales then with Bonnie here in the
studio Bonnie let's talk about some of
what Ben measure then by just discussing
this by just talking about the figures
from the weekend are we emboldening
Trump's campaign well you can't embolden
Donald Trump any more than he's born to
be this is how this guy rolls and I'm
saying as a former New Yorker I mean
Donald Trump's been in the fire for you
know 30 40 50 years they've even got a
headline on the New York Times there was
in the 70s about the trouble he was in
so Donald has kind of been in this water
for a long time and Ben is right you
know courses is going to Galvanize his
followers anything with Galvanize his
followers so you know if he ate a ham
sandwich in front of you know whatever
that would Galvanize them so that's not
the issue it's also if the Republican
party is crazy enough to actually run
him which would be super hope he's going
to get beaten again see the thing is
this and I think that that what's
overlooked
the United States is a country of laws
not men I don't know who said that but
that is a quote the district attorney is
an elected official and the district
attorney determines within his or her
District what the law is the feds don't
get involved and people from the outside
don't get involved now this case will
fall or rise tomorrow in the court when
the judge decides whether it's worth it
and the other thing we need to remember
is this indictment was brought by
ordinary Americans not by the district
attorney it's brought by the grand jury
so he brings the case they decide and
then the judge says okay I like it or I
don't that's it and that was a point I
wanted to bring up with uh Ben so thanks
for explaining that especially to our
British viewers and our other
International viewers how the US justice
system works because as Bonnie brightly
pointed out that it's a grand jury it's
a pair of normal people in this court uh
Ben the district attorney democratically
nominated yes but if you are saying as
many sort of Transporters or gosp
supporters are that it's a politically
motivated Witch Hunt and it's a sham
trial and not my words but the words are
plenty of supporters out there is that
not saying there's something wrong with
the U.S justice system
no because look grand juries are very
much uh not connected to the back story
on these types of indictments I'll give
you a great example the grand jury
doesn't know that the federal government
refused to prosecute and said there was
no crime here the grand jury also
doesn't know that they are turning a
misdemeanor into a felony that's the
problem with this case you can get
indictments and there are there are
countless hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of indictments that have been
thrown out immediately and or on appeal
you are in a very limited box when
you're on a grand jury and your job is
to look at what they put in front of you
you have an activist D.A that's
selectively giving you information you
don't understand the back story here you
don't understand the FED said there's no
crime here you don't know that the
former D.A said there's no crime here
and you don't know all of these things
so when he comes in and he says to you
here is my case they may not even
realize that he has created out of thin
air a felony that doesn't exist this
will be thrown out mark my word it will
be thrown out and that's where this D.A
is going to have egg on his face Ben we
don't know the details of uh the exact
challenges yet of course we'll have to
wait for that area
Ben's also given the beauty of the grand
jury system they aren't a bunch of
lawyers they aren't people who went to
Harvard lawyer law they aren't
politicians they aren't political
commentators they're Joe Blow and his
wife from the street and they decided
that this needed to go to a judge the
judge then decides no this isn't this he
might throw it out tomorrow that's his
job good job of the people Ben let me
finish the job of the people is
determine what it looks like to them now
again it could be thrown out Trump is
innocent until proven guilty and that's
the end of this story until he's until
the judge rules if he rules tomorrow Ben
it's not the end of story because this
political harassment has been going on
since 2016 and by the way Hillary
Clinton if you're going to claim that
Donald Trump has committed this crime uh
well I'm saying I'm saying that I'm
saying the prosecutor I'm saying the
prosecutor all right let me care Alvin
Bragg is saying that Donald Trump took
money and he said it was legal fees when
it actually wasn't and it was a hush
payment if that is true then you would
have to go back and charge Hillary
Clinton for the exact same crime in the
exact same year in the exact same place
New York City she had the steel dossier
there's no shaking the head here this is
the fact no I am shaking yeah
let me finish hold on let me just finish
because people need to understand this
around the world Hillary Clinton paid
for the still dossier they they labeled
that in her campaign Finance report as
legal Feast she was found guilty of
doing that wrong and the FCC forced her
and the Democratic National Committee to
pay a fine and even then a D.A did not
say that she should be charged Criminal
of the day
this is not some kind of thing in the
back in the day of the day
this is an ancient history make this is
today now somebody wants to come up and
somebody wants to come up and charge
Hillary Clinton well fine nobody's done
it let's bring it back I'm not doing it
because this is political and and going
after don't talk because they hate them
Hillary Clinton
six years ago too late then I'm not
trying to gloss over history I see the
point you're making but let's bring it
to the present day let's bring it back
to Donald Trump that list that we read
out at the beginning of the show uh
January 6 Georgia 2020 uh the dossier of
documents at Mar-A-Lago when you look at
all that in sort of entirety isn't it
the case the American people deserve a
bit better on the behavior standards
I I think they deserve better from
activists what prosecutors have been put
in by George Soros who are trying to
take out their political opponents the
leader of the Republican party and
that's been their Obsession since 2016.
I also think this is a dangerous
precedent let me explain why are you
seriously we are doing this let me
finish the fact that we are doing this
and I don't believe that anyone by the
way should charge Hillary Clinton with a
crime that we talked about earlier I
think you don't charge people like this
because you don't like them I don't
think you weaponize like a third world
country and Communists and dictators and
tyrants the judicial system high school
stuff where does George
how does George Soros get into this
George Soros back Alvin Brad you should
know that he was the top donor to Alvin
Williams
songs
because it does get very toxic that side
of the debate but I just want to ask
them ask Bonnie then is it is it a
politically motivated Witch Hunt can you
see a little bit of what Ben is saying
they're given that this is a Democrat
State there's a Democrat D.A in charge
could you are you able to bend to that
position let no and I I'm going to say
this to Ben because he's got the same
name let me let me speak sir because
he's got the same let me speak let me
speak please
I will give this to Ben okay
a D.A is elected and runs on a platform
and Alvin Bragg made no bones about
wanting to get Donald Trump okay
so in that sense in quotes every D.A is
politically motivated the deal is you
take hang on the deal is you take it to
the Grand Jury the grand jury says yep
or no if the grand jury says yes it goes
to the judge then the judge says I like
this or it's I'm throwing it out end of
and that's how it works in the United
States Ben yeah I mean you either
believe in your own justice system or
you you don't if you begin to pick away
at these institutions of democracy
system I believe in the justice system
but I also think they're bad actors in
every sector of Life we've had bad
actors that are priests we've had bad
actors or teachers we've had bad actors
in law enforcement well Republicans
no matter what no I said in every sector
Bonnie I said in every sector okay and
I'll go back to what I was saying a
moment ago Alvin Bragg ran and this is
going to be the problem when he gets up
into the higher courts on appeal and
this is going to fall apart he ran and
he was on the record hell he was doing
TV interviews the week he was indicting
Donald Trump he's a partisan guy who
said vote for me and I'll nail Trump you
show me Donald Trump and I will find you
at crime and by the way he's wanting to
run for governor this is all political
that yeah what I said before it met
Alvin Bragg has to take it to the Grand
Jury he doesn't bring it up and we
already talked about the grand jury the
grand jury has a very limited scope of
understanding
because if you're complaining about the
grand jury which is what you're doing
then you don't I'm talking about the
reality
how a grand jury works and the fact is
when this goes to a judge and they see
the bias of Alvin Bragg and they see
that he created charges out of thin air
that are not felonies out of a
misdemeanor that has already reached its
statute of limitations it will be thrown
out and you guys are gonna you might be
right you might be right you might be
right yeah
but don't knock the grand jury system
there we go I'm saying the United States
of America this has been fascinating to
listen to to find out more about the
system Ben Ferguson Bonnie gray thank
you both for your insights your input
we're just getting started Trump hasn't
even landed in New York